I also made another prediction six years
and half ago I said United States and
China both needed political reforms but
in the case of China small reforms have
been going on all the time in the
political system we fix problem here and
there
I said problem is the United States your
political system was product or
pre-industrial year and I made a
forecast I said without significant
substantial political reform
my concern is in your next elections you
will produce a leader worse off than
george w bush so it was you it was not
the russians so so this is the chinese
humble but we can offer china is a
civilization of state I remember when
Henry Kissinger wrote his famous book on
China
he started with this quote he said but
goodness look at this China it's
different Chan you this unique language
which started 3,500 years ago it's one
thousand years earlier their agent Greek
one Sun five years earlier than agent
Latin but these two European language
with dead languages China still use the
same language this line of culture and
continuation of civilization are
interrupted so this is a why we have
indeed in her for instance this whole
idea of meritocracy why say confident I
said with my debate with professor
Fukuyama I said if look at the top
leadership in China we've just had
people's the parties Congress minimal
requirement to terms of provincial
governor or similar position which we
have to govern at least 100 million
people given the size of China before
you came to one of the top seven
positions decision-making bodies I said
to Fukuyama said with this Chinese
methodology meritocracy based the system
we can say with certainty we can improve
this is their problems we can fix it but
we will not produce any leaders like
George W Bush you know it's we build
Chinese buying that's my point
I respect deeply modern respect I admire
Chinese civilization
I admire Chinese history I have been all
my life an admirer of Chinese art since
I was a very young man China has been
one of my compass of my life but I don't
admire your political system and I feel
I find much more admirable and worth of
respect a system when you have the right
to make a strike when you have the right
to be paid decently when you have the
right to speak freely when you have the
right to not to be contaminated by
terrible pollution and so on so I I will
not say in the name of quality vism and
so on that every political regime are
equivalent I don't believe so I really
think that Europe invented an idea which
does not belong to Europe that migrated
to America that has been adopted by a
lot of parts of Latin America that is
incarnated in part of Asia which is a
universal ID which is the idea of a
freedom of equality and so on and China
of today is not worshiping these values
and that's why I do hope I hope I would
be happy I would not say that which
surprised I'm surprised if there was one
day
a real Chinese spring a real cultural
revolution as the one I saw in my youth
of Chinese people saying is good to have
wealth is good to have gross product is
good to have exploitation but is good
also to have human rights I think that
this would be a great news forum for
Humanity you said that
Weiwei have these equivalents between
political systems but he does not have
equivalents he has a clear preference he
believes that our authoritarian systems
are superior to democracy he explicitly
said that democracy yields to bad
governance if I'm not mistaken so my
question to you there are millions of
people today in the world that live
under bad governance systems which are
democracies China has a different view
and therefore you countries tend to like
than to be very tempted to export their
models they like to see what they do
replicated elsewhere so would you
recommend to your government to go out
in the world and promote what you think
is good governance and and unless they
mock you know promote the cause of less
democracy or non democracy actually it
depends on how do you define democracy I
like this Nexxus foreign because you
said at very beginning that we discussed
the Riu meaning of democracy real
democracy but unfortunately so far what
we see as showing up spring about
one-person one-vote a multi-party system
that's at the best procedure democracy
that's non-si the real democracy
emergency is a far more import a you say
about education bombing other important
ideas in terms of China you know let me
quote from everybody knows Confucius
yeah and he said people are like water
regime or leaders are like both water
can carry the boat can also overturn the
boat so if you look at the channel model
in particular the key messages stay in
touch with your people it's so easy
illegal to ethic don't go there with
your brilliant ideas I respect your
preference it's understandable why you
do some service
what are the I care about most fighting
poverty fighting disease street security
safety etc job creation you do this
accordingly one two three four that's
how China did would your memories of the
world to go that way and repress their
options that he described though it's
not his definition it's really people
should sit down and discuss what kind of
political system with your people we are
doing that yeah we should expect channel
of an option which is very interesting
because we have the four decades of
successful China should export that view
ranking said in his report China China's
experience can offer a entirely new
alternative for those countries and
nations who desire for quick
modernization and complete independence
state supported export no no it's not
actually China is the Chinese are very
modest I'm being slightly in the less
modest
chara do not explore this model do not
advocate is model but once you're
successful you go to Africa people talk
about looking East they have tried West
Mordor for decades not working you know
to these just talk here about the about
the oppressed Muslim minority so don't
tell me that everybody is fine there is
an oppressed minority in China and then
I want to bring up something else here
with it in terms of terrible things that
are happening today like in in Syria and
it's what is happening to the revenger
Muslims and the way I look at it is I
thought it was never again and to me
never again meant a Muslim or a
Christian or Jewish or Yazidis or black
or white or any color but today we are
seeing a genocide and I don't see China
has also quite a lot of influence in a
place like burner like Myanmar
apart from I don't want to even talk
about North Korea but I don't see
anything anybody doing anything for for
the Muslims in Myanmar or the Muslims in
China also you this question first it's
important because you know that you know
because I told if we go in a
conversation in which you are saying how
good you you are always saying that when
you're not very good but in a certain
way the problem is that part of the
Western democracy is also problem
today's that we lost curiosity on the
others obviously China's legitimacy is
not based on coercion only and if we are
not seeing this we are basically playing
a game but on the other side I do
believe what you're also giving is a
totally and critical story because every
political regime is successful under
certain conditions and not others I do
believe one of the biggest problem that
we have we've forgot what are the real
advantages of democracy the real
advantage of democracy is not simply
rights but this is that when people are
disappointed
you're giving them a mechanism through
which they can react democracy is not
famous for doing the right things but
democracy is famous for changing the
governments that people don't like
without
my question is the following the Chinese
system at the moment Marvel works fine
based on the incredibly important
economic performance how strong is the
system if economic performance is not
there so if we want to be serious we
should be open to the vulnerability of
both regimes because otherwise we go in
a rhetorical story which probably could
opera performance but it is not helping
us more and just on Bernard and Olivia I
do believe that the Spanish government
should be very happy that you went to
Kurdish regions and didn't end up in
Catalunya at the same moment and I think
that China will not go so far as you
think and maybe as China deserves if he
stays on this path if you really believe
that the owing a problem is a form of
faith if you really believe that the we
go problem is a form of religion
religion it means that really you you
yuppie your Western your leadership has
not understand how really a great power
has to work in order to succeed because
it is a human rights question it is a
democratic subject and it is not NGOs of
the West who are this is a plot theory
it's absurd it is people who are in
despair the hunger is terrible
nobody knew nobody knew in the West
except a few of us who the hunger where
there are the most miserable people in
the world they have no rights have we
been to that no identity I've ever been
to this region you have conceded rape in
my eyes must and I frame i I have been
alas I am elder than you and I went to
this very baby you can see crucified in
the Saudi surveys I will give you
another face paint my delicious
between Bangladesh and Roma no entry I
know exactly what analytical advice of a
cursed Muslim people in this environment
I know that they are there man
deprived of any rights and I know what
is that in front of that you cannot feel
something else than despair and they are
despair and that's why they revolted and
the way in which they are treated is and
others
mind your own business first I don't
it's 89 percent versus new beacon child
anyway it's you know really too little
about Charlie to not little dangerous
with 130 million visits abroad three
minutes to don't send me about still
knowledge because that's not the right
way that we cannot agree to you I I
would like to bring in something
different
you